they would if they were known from a
security perspective and they were not
on any active watch lists of course the
police are currently questioning those
in custody so beyond that there's not
too much more I can say at this time I
think that gives you an indication there
at least from debt and that regard is
they weren't on watchlist so it's not a
matter of someone having slipped under
the radar again though it is early days
that's the assurance I can give people
at this time people are in custody
obviously being questioned the
Commissioner of Police will be giving an
update again roughly somewhere between 8
and 8:30 those are questions there
perhaps you can put to him again I think
we should be vigilant against the idea
of extreme ideology and extreme violence
and violent acts focus you'll notice
from the language that you hear from
those who work in our intelligence and
security services that their focus is on
extremism regardless of where it comes
from we need to be blind in that regard
it needs to absolutely focused on threat
and ideology and extremism
because obviously that is what we have
experienced here today we have
undoubtedly experienced an attack today
that is unprecedented unlike anything
that we have experienced before but as I
say New Zealand has been chosen because
we are not a place where violent
extremism exists we reject those notions
and we must continue to reject them this
is not an enclave for that kind of
behavior for that kind of ideology we
will and must reject it this is a place
where people should feel secure and will
feel secure I am NOT going to let this
change New Zealand's profile none of us
should mister
word on the Intelligence Agency's
watchlist why not
obviously Barry it's an indication to
you that they had not acted in a way
that warranted it again though feel free
to ask through the questions at this
time I'm not in a place to give you
additional information beyond that my
understanding at the stage is that they
weren't on watch lists again I don't
want to go too much beyond this it is
early days you'll also understand I
won't want to jeopardize the case that
may be taken in the future as well I do
also want to acknowledge that I have
been contacted by prime minister Scott
Morrison I team to speak with him
directly as soon as I'm able not at this
stage but I'm certainly the Minister of
Foreign Affairs and the Prime Minister
of Australia who have contacted the
Deputy Prime Minister and myself not at
this stage I will have been amongst
other members of the public who will
have seen the footage as the injured
were being brought to Christ suit Amy
and you certainly can see from that
footage there is a real range of Ages
there I imagine that these would have
represented particular brothers fathers
sons I haven't had a breakdown at this
stage sorry it's not information I can
share
[Music]
these are obviously questions that at
this point I'm unable to give additional
details on obviously though that
offender is in custody now so I can give
that assurance he has been apprehended
he is also accompanied by two other
associates he has been actively
questioned obviously these may be
additional questions that you could put
to the Commissioner of Police
obviously absolutely again as I say I've
given you the advice I've given me about
watch lists but obviously these these
are absolutely questions that we'll be
asking including access to firearms this
stage I'm certainly asking people to
continue to follow the advice of the
police yes we have ever hindered their
helping three individuals apprehended
however the police aren't taking for
granted that there may may well be
others that that may need to be brought
into custody they've got no reason to
expect that but they haven't ruled it
out so please in the meantime continue
to listen to police advice but I I also
want to give assurance to people the
police are obviously incredibly active
on the ground they are bringing in
additional police officers the Defence
Force are bringing them down so just
listen to the advice that's available to
you but we are ensuring the security of
those who are moving around in
Christchurch at this time they're not
directly connected to the attack
sewing over your wrists and question
that is my understanding is in
connection to the attacks today or the
individuals that wasn't there would be a
question for commissioner Bush I'm not
sure if there's something kind of able
to dis year but they're not anyone who
is a threat to the public certainly that
is the assumption that I would make at
this stage we've seen from one of the
offenders that they have publicized
their ideology I have no reason to
assume anything other than that those
others who have been arrested would
subscribe to the same ideology which I
can only describe as lenders I'm not in
a position to give away additional
details on their on the citizenship at
this stage Barry you know point I think
that's an opportunity to really
acknowledge the work that the police are
doing you know the air-breathing
apprehending of a of a suspect and an
extremely volatile situation really
putting themselves at risk on our
behalves and I want to acknowledge that
particularly also disarming the
explosives that were as I understand
attached to the suspects cars there were
two of them they have been disarmed now
but obviously that was a high-risk
situation gives us an indication that
there was a degree of planning around
what has happened today
I cannot speculate around what the
intention was but again it was attached
to the suspects suspects vehicles no not
at this stage
follow you on the video I'd rather share
you're watching the like my message
would be you know we should not be
perpetuating sharing giving any oxygen
to this act of violence and the message
that set behind it we should all be
condemning obviously what has happened
here today and the peaceful nation of
New Zealand and what all of us can at
least do is ensure that we do not share
spread or actively engage in that
message of hate we have been given
assurance that online at least those
platforms where some of those images
have been shared are actively being
removed but I just ask people don't
share them this is not who we are
this act was not a reflection of who we
are as a nation that is why so many New
Zealanders every New Zealand or I
imagine will be shocked by this today
because this isn't who we are you know
this is something that we all of us will
utterly reject and of course it will
take time to heal and tonight our
thoughts and our prayers need to be with
those affected but I'm sure of course
that all of us want to retain the
identity we have as a nation because
that's why those who live here live here
of course our agencies always need to be
prepared we need to be vigilant we need
to ensure that if we have a an act like
this on our shores that we respond
quickly to a give assurances to the
public that we can protect them and
maybe safety as top of mind
so we are always prepared we've
personally prepared for these things to
happen an event like this of course is
always a shock but for our agencies we
were ready we must always be vigilant
obviously we've lifted our threat level
from low to high that's of course so
that we can continue to give assurance
to the public around this safety it
means we have heightened our response
from our agencies at the border at the
airport in fact at every level we have a
heightened response and again that's so
we can give that assurance of of safety
to the public as I say of course events
like this we always have preparations in
place and of course we'll always be
working to ensure that we've adequately
responded I'm very keen to travel as
soon as I can but of course within
reason taking advice from the police
around when I can do that in such a way
that doesn't interfere with their
operational work my hope is that that
the very latest that I'll be down there
tomorrow may have come directly to the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and Trade
but at least I know directly certainly
from Australia at this stage often
messages are conveyed via social media
as well and I'm sure everyone would want
to thank them for their thoughts and
their offer of assistance
the hospital whether there were any
shots fired or whether there was a
resurgence no no I haven't I haven't had
any information that that confirms that
at all no it was an IUD found on an
individual no I cannot confirm that do
feel free to put that question to the
commissioner presumably you'll be having
more meetings of their intelligence
agencies to find out just what went on
why they these people would miss when
are you going to be meeting the team
again the craic speaks I am likely to
reconvene with them again this evening
you will appreciate and bury that at the
moment our immediate response is on
ensuring the safety of those in
Christchurch ensuring that the police
have everything they need from an
operational perspective to secure the
areas and be assured that everyone who
should be in custody is acknowledging
that they have moved extremely quickly
to have those individuals already in
custody of course we will continue to
look at the details around the suspects
and every element of this attack but
tonight it's about securing the safety
of others
at the stage again as I say three have
been arrested we have no reason to
suspect at this stage there were others
but we haven't obviously ruled that out
at this stage why do you use firearms I
cannot give you a hundred percent sure
and assurance of that but certainly all
three are connected look at the stage
obviously I'm one of the members of
parliament that always has a security
detail with me obviously the moment that
we were informed of this situation there
was a slightly heightened presence and
that I expected it there soon that will
probably resume back to to my normal
presence there were defenders who look I
can't give specifics around who was
directly involved at each mosque and nor
am I'm sure at this stage that that's
detail that we're sharing do feel free
to put the question to the commissioner
though
that is my understanding to do something
really sorry to do something for that
wasn't apparently you know the stage
advice has been given to to those who
would usually wish to worship at their
local mosque and that for the time being
they're being asked to to just not to
congregate there but in time my hope
would be that the outpouring of
compassion and support that I know New
Zealanders will want to show show it to
them shout to the members of the
community who sought to worship safely
and who were the victims of this of this
attack today and I know New Zealanders
will want to do them
my understanding that it is a relatively
short period of time since last entry
into New Zealand again I don't want to
get into too many details around there
because that's still an emerging picture
they weren't on on a watch list again
I'm cautious around how much more I say
given that we have individuals in
custody and I don't want to jeopardize
the case but that may be detail that the
Commissioner maybe weren't willing to
share all right everyone look I'll look
to reconvene and give you any additional
insights I can tomorrow and we'll be
keeping everyone updated my plan is just
get to Christchurch as early as I can
and as soon as the police are happy for
me to do so doing office no I certainly
can't confirm that there's nothing I've
been briefed on we'll make sure that the
Commission is able to give you
information as soon as possible thank
you everyone
Prime Minister Justin der are doing just
leaving a press conference there the
leader of a nation tonight whose
innocence
hairs well and truly
[Music]